a notable bio webwriter has left the
company off to almost 20 years his name
is Mac Walters and he was the lead
writer on Mass Effect 2 and 3 and
production director on Dragon Age dread
wolf he shared the news on LinkedIn
initially saying with a new year comes
new adventures as some of you already
know at the end of last year I decided
to leave BioWare these past 19 years
have been a life-changing experience to
say the least and it made the choice to
go very difficult I've worked with so
many wonderful people and had the
privilege to be a part of the most
amazing teams and projects it's hard to
Fathom it all and I know I'll be
reflecting on it for years to come he
said thank you to everyone I've had the
joy of working with and I wish everyone
at BioWare the very best on everything
they do it's truly been a pleasure sad
to see Walters go as he was a phenomenal
writer and such an influential part of
Mass Effect 2 and 3 which are
fantastically well written games but
also people leave Studios and change
jobs all the time the fact that he
stayed for 20 years is a huge deal
doesn't necessarily mean that anything's
majorly wrong